it is time for the long-awaited deep
dive into race and IQ that we've been
working on a lot of time has gone into
this producer Noah Ferguson has done
some great research and editing and this
is exactly the type of work that we can
do more of the more support we have from
you so with no further ado remember
membership patreon if you like this type
of detailed video and audio
investigation please continue supporting
us and let's get right into part one of
race and IQ today the topic of race and
intelligence can be sort of
uncomfortable to discuss for a lot of
people and it's a subject that's very
often steeped in identity politics
there's a lot of people on the Left who
don't want to touch the issue or at
least they don't want to have a
conversation about the fact that yes
certain races do score higher or lower
on IQ tests but then there's many on the
right who want to use IQ tests to make
false claims about genetics and other
matters it is true that in the United
States white people as defined on
average score higher on IQ tests than
Hispanic people and black people and
it's also true that Asian Americans on
average score higher than white
Americans on IQ tests but the key is not
to misinterpret this information to take
IQ scores and conclude that some races
are genetically more intelligent than
others you have to rely on several false
assumptions just looking at IQ test
scores does not tell us that certain
races are genetically smarter than
others for a number of different reasons
iq is not an objective measure of innate
general intelligence intelligence is
complicated and intelligence manifests
in a number of ways linguistic skills
logical and mathematical skills spatial
reasoning introspective skills
interpersonal skills kinesthetic skills
most aspects of intelligence are just
not tested for on IQ tests so
intelligence manifests in a number of
ways but biologically intelligence
itself is also not a unified genetic
trait that we can even discuss as a
single phenomenon with a single genetic
driver the
another major problem with trying to
link race and intelligence which is that
race as a biological construct is not
something that can be defined concretely
and specifically enough and thus you
can't really measure it against other
genetic traits like intelligence there
simply aren't enough genetic
similarities within races to tie an
entire race to a small set of genetic
traits like intelligence the concept of
race is essentially meaningless in
biology and thus races meaningless as an
independent variable in studies about
intelligence and genetics but even when
we are just talking about IQ there's a
lot of data out there suggesting that IQ
is largely based on environmental
factors during a person's development IQ
tests don't measure innate intellectual
capacity they measure certain obtained
intellectual skills that are more common
among certain social groups and as we'll
discuss higher socioeconomic status
causes higher IQ because higher
socioeconomic environments foster the
skills that are actually measured by IQ
tests many people simply claim that
certain races are just less intelligent
because they're genetically born with
less intelligence and it's easy to shut
down debate about race and intelligence
with accusations of racism it's easy to
stigmatize people and their claims about
race and intelligence simply by calling
them bigots but alleging racism isn't
the same as proving that an argument is
fallacious or that the data have been
misused having a moral objection to
someone's assertions about race and IQ
is one thing and sometimes those moral
objections are justified because some
people really are just racist but
proving someone wrong requires us to
examine the facts and I would like to do
exactly that let's start with the brief
history of attempts to tie race with
genetic intelligence for centuries many
white researchers have been eager to
prove the intellectual superiority of
white people and they've used any number
of non-scientific means for the 18th and
19th centuries before modern
standardized
intelligence testing we saw researchers
making assumptions about intelligence
differences between races based on
primitive and totally absurd means of
testing like measuring skull and brain
size measuring cranial volume to make
racial claims about intelligence was
total pseudoscience practiced by
prominent scientists like Dutch
physician Petrus Kemper an American
anthropologist Samuel George Morton
measuring a dead person's skull can tell
you something about the size of their
brain but not about their intelligence
and in fact excess brain tissue is
linked to a number of neurological
disorders in 1913 at the dawn of
standardized intelligence testing
prominent American psychologist and
eugenicist Henry Goddard established a
written intelligence test at Ellis
Island not only has this test been shown
to have put ethnic minorities at Alice
Island at a disadvantage it was later
discovered that the only subjects being
chosen to even take the test were
immigrants who were already suspected to
have lower intelligence this testing
program reported that 87% of Russians
83% of Jews 80% of Hungarians and 79% of
Italians were quote feeble-minded and
had a quote mental age younger than 12
and Goddard's test had real-world
effects the reporting from these tests
directly influenced Congress's passing
of the Immigration Act of 1924 which
essentially ended Ellis Island as an
immigration hub and drastically limited
immigration into the United States in
general another prominent figure in the
early days of intelligence testing was
English psychologist and Nazi
sympathizer Raymond Cattell who in the
1930s did research that concluded that
the average British IQ was going down
because of non-white immigration into
Britain his conclusions were eventually
disproved by what we know today which is
that the IQ of most human populations
has actually been increasing since the
beginning of the 20th century but
regardless katella's work was extremely
influential and he used his research to
loudly advocate against the mixing of
races and then we come to American
physicist William Shockley who became
famous as an out
and proponent of eugenics starting with
his address to the 1965 Nobel conference
where he said that non-whites were
causing the quote genetic deterioration
of humans Shockley's findings have since
been debunked again by the consensus
today that human intelligence is
constantly improving around the world
Shockley spent much of his career
throughout the 20th century arguing that
blacks are intellectually inferior to
whites because of genetics and that we
should not try to remedy this through
education he said instead we should just
try to limit the birth rates of
non-white people by using contraception
and sterilization Shockley said that
individuals with IQs lower than 100
should be sterilized our discussion of
William Shockley makes it necessary for
me to bring up an institution that has
played an important role in studying and
advocating for eugenics in the 20th
century a great deal of Shockley's
writings and lectures were funded by an
American nonprofit organization called
the pioneer fund which was founded in
1937 with the goal of achieving what
they called race betterment through
promoting the genes of white people back
then and still to this day the pioneer
Fund has primarily existed to fund
eugenic studies the pioneer fund has
ties to Nazi Germany during the 1930s
and 40s and for the last 60 years
they've been funding the International
Association for the Advancement of
eugenics and ethnology which is an
organization that promotes racial
segregation they've given over a million
dollars to eugenicist Arthur Jensen
who's known as the father of modern
academic racism one of the pioneer
fund's biggest beneficiaries over the
last twenty years has been you Genesis
Roger Pearson who spent his career
working with neo-nazis to advocate for
the superiority of the so-called Aryan
race recent pioneer fund grantees have
included white supremacist like Jared
Taylor as well as several organizations
listed as racist hate groups by the
Southern Poverty Law Center and here's
something very interesting the pioneer
fund has also given money to a group
called the Federation for American
immigration reform which is an
organization with ties to white
supremacy several of that organization's
highest-ranking employees now work at
the White House
whenever there are people painstakingly
conducting what sometimes may appear to
be objective research to prove the
superiority of white people or people in
government trying to shape policy based
on an agenda that non-whites are harmful
to society there is often an
organization like the Pioneer fund
quietly looming in the background
providing funding somewhere down the
line and no discussion about race and
intelligence would be complete without
mentioning what's probably the most well
known book ever published on the subject
the 1994 book written by political
scientist Charles Murray and
psychologist Richard Bernstein called
the bell curve the bell curve is widely
thought of as a work of pop science
because it was aimed at a general public
audience it was not submitted for peer
review before publication
it wasn't even allowed to be circulated
among book reviewers before being
published
like most nonfiction books are but the
book created a huge stir in popular
culture when it was published in 1994
and the bell curve is one of the most
commonly cited books today by modern
white supremacists and eugenicist s--
although it was published twenty-three
years ago the book has seen somewhat of
a revival in sales over the past few
years with the rise of the alt-right and
author Charles Murray's recent college
speaking gigs the book tries to bring
back to life a bunch of theories about
race and IQ that have long been
discredited and some of the book central
claims are that IQ tests are the best
measures of cognitive ability that IQ
tests aren't biased against any economic
ethnic or racial groups that
non-hispanic white Americans are
naturally more intelligent than black
and Hispanic Americans that IQ has more
of an impact on someone's success in
life than their childhood socioeconomic
status and environmental factors and
that IQ in the u.s. is declining because
we're allowing too many low IQ people in
other words non-white people to
immigrate to the United States the bell
curves conclusions about race and IQ
largely draw from studies by 13
researchers and these studies cited in
the book were funded by guess who the
Pioneer fund again the pie
your fund is a nonprofit that promotes
eugenics and has direct ties to white
supremacists several times the bell
curve cites studies conducted by Jay
Philippe Rushton who for many years was
the head of the pioneer fund Rushton has
said that black people are biologically
predisposed to break the law have lower
intelligence and are more impulsive
Rushton once said quote blacks of an
advantage in sport because they have
narrower hips but they have narrower
hips because they have smaller brains
Rushton has also said that intelligence
has an inverse correlation with penis
size Jay Phillipe Russians research has
been universally dismissed by the
scientific community because of its
flaws and biases but these are the kind
of people whose research is used in
Marie's the bell curve but we have to
remember that the claims made in the
bell curve aren't wrong because of the
motivations of the authors and the
researchers that are cited the bell
curve has problems because it doesn't
stand up scientifically the book drew so
much attention when it was published
that the following year the American
Psychological Association commissioned a
report by 11 leading intelligence
experts to address the claims made in
the book the report was called
intelligence knowns and unknowns the APA
said that the bell curve created serious
misunderstandings and that there was
urgent need for an authoritative report
on these issues one that all sides could
use as a basis for discussion in this
report in the response to the bell curve
the APA said there is certainly no such
support for a genetic interpretation it
is sometimes suggested that the
black/white differential in psychometric
intelligence is partly due to genetic
differences there is not much direct
evidence on this point but what little
there is fails to support the genetic
hypothesis and it shouldn't be any
surprise that neither of the bell curves
authors actually worked in biology or
any hard science there's a mountain of
scholarship directly debunking the
claims made in the bell curve the APA
along with a multitude of intelligence
experts have agreed that the bell curve
like most other modern attempts to link
genetic intelligence to race rely on a
few fundamental assumptions that are
just not supported by science one
that there must be enough genetic
differences between races and enough
genetic similarities within races to
biologically tie intelligence to race
that IQ test scores must be synonymous
with general intelligence and innate
intelligence and that intelligence must
be primarily based on genetics and not
on environment let's start with the
first false assertion that it's
legitimate to even have a conversation
about genetic intelligence in terms of
race the truth is trying to figure out
the average genetic intelligence of
different races is essentially arbitrary
and meaningless first of all over time
there have been countless definitions of
race people throughout history have
divided humans into races in many
different ways and even today different
people in different parts of the world
use varying definitions when they're
talking about race for instance are
people from India and people from Japan
part of the same race what about people
from Spain and people from Russia you're
going to get different answers to those
questions in different contexts but even
in the way we talk about race today in
the u.s. things don't have that much
biological basis let's say that some
examples we accept of races are white
black maybe East Asian maybe Native
American these labels have a lot of
important social significance which is
why the idea of race is valid when we're
talking about the census or political
polls but there is no such thing as race
in genetics and biology so studies that
examine correlations between genetic
race and innate intelligence are
inherently flawed from the get-go the
United Nations Educational Scientific
and Cultural Organization declared as
early as 1950 that there is no such
thing as race in biology based on the
findings of an international panel of
leading anthropologists geneticists
sociologists and psychologists and this
is still the scientific consensus today
supported by the National Institutes of
Health the American Medical Association
the American Psychological Association
and the American Anthropological
Association in the study of genetics
there is no way to break humans up into
races now that is not to say that there
isn't genetic variation between humans
populations there obviously is but race
is biologically not a definable
construct there is no white gene or
black gene there is no one gene that all
people from a given race have in
genetics there is no such thing as
blackness or whiteness genetic variation
is fluid it's possible to use DNA to
figure out where someone comes from
geographically with some accuracy but no
one who believes in genetic races is
able to accurately tell us which genes
should be tested to determine someone's
race people subjectively make social
distinctions about race based on things
like skin color hair and eye shape which
are based in genetics but the crucial
thing to understand is that those traits
don't predict everything else about a
person's entire genetic makeup someone's
skin color doesn't necessarily tell you
whether or not they're going to have
dimples or whether or not colorblindness
runs in their family skin color also
doesn't tell you anything about a
person's intelligence so maybe you're
thinking well hold on certain races are
more susceptible to certain diseases so
why can't certain races be smarter than
others here's one example there's this
common misconception that black people
people with African heritage as a race
are genetically inclined to get
sickle-cell anemia
not exactly true the misconception goes
like this skin colour is inherited and
sickle cell disease is inherited
therefore sickle cell disease is caused
by race susceptibility to sickle cell is
a response to a certain population being
exposed to malaria for a long period of
time over many generations and malaria
is only rampant in certain parts of
Africa
so only people of African descent that
come from certain parts of Africa have
the gene for sickle-cell not all black
people and by the way there has also
historically been a lot of malaria in
southern Europe the Middle East and
South Asia and populations from those
regions also have the sickle cell gene
it's not a black phenomenon humans can
be split up into separate populations
that have significant
similar genetics but these populations
are confined to relatively small
geographical regions for example two
people with 100% of their genetic
heritage coming from the same village in
Eastern Europe many generations ago are
likely to have significant genetic
similarities but when you compare those
people with someone of Scottish genetic
heritage their end up being far fewer
genetic similarities so even though a
fully Eastern European person and a
fully Scottish person both appear to be
white and in many cases these two people
may be ethnically indistinguishable in
their appearance
it's useless to lump them into the same
category as white in order to test for
other outcomes like intelligence we
don't yet know which genes are
associated with intelligence but we
can't assume that whatever genetics are
manifesting make them both appear white
are also tied in with all other genetic
traits they may have like their
intelligence there are just not enough
genetic similarities within what we
refer to as a race to make assumptions
about other aspects of a person's
genetics there's even huge genetic
variation within local regions like
Scandinavia or the Iberian Peninsula or
Southeast Asia there are several
thousand genetically similar human
populations on earth you have to go to a
very micro level geographically to find
humans with significant genetic
similarities and 85% of human genetic
variation takes place within these tiny
individual populations so even comparing
these small local populations wouldn't
necessarily give us any useful data
about intelligence much less comparing
people by continent classifying all of
these thousands of groups in order to
further test for outcomes like
intelligence in a meaningful way would
be really difficult but it's especially
meaningless to report findings about a
very specific set of genetic traits like
intelligence in relation to someone's
skin color or continent of origin and
biologically measuring anything in terms
of race is especially problematic in the
Western Hemisphere because it's so
common for people's genetics to have a
multitude of geographical origins even
though people socially
if I with a particular race if someone
in the u.s. is five-eighths black and
three-eighths white they will probably
for social reasons identify as black
because they look like what we think of
as a black person so even if
intelligence was tied to race how would
we know which intelligence genes are
being expressed in that person are they
manifesting the black intelligence or
the white intelligence very few people
in the u.s. can trace their ancestry
back to a single place the average
african-american genome is twenty four
percent European the average American
Latino genome is 18 percent Native
American 65 percent European and six
percent African and where those genetics
come from within those continents is
also going to vary a lot so when someone
takes an IQ test and simply tells you
their race there are a ton of genetic
variables that are just not being
accounted for another big problem with
using IQ tests to judge the average
innate intelligence of different races
is assuming that IQ is the same as a
person's general intelligence like I
said before the idea of intelligence is
very complex and it manifests in a
number of different ways it's like
trying to measure if someone is a nice
person
what are we really measuring we
shouldn't discount IQ tests wholesale
because IQ tests are good at measuring
what it is that they measure but the
important thing is not to misinterpret
IQ there's a common misconception that
IQ is a measure of someone's overall
intelligence that they're born with that
is not what IQ is and any intelligence
expert will tell you that a person's
general intelligence can't be summed up
by one number IQ tests measure only a
set of specific skills and these skills
have to be acquired all IQ test measure
is a person's ability to perform
particular cognitive tasks like reading
comprehension a person's ability to work
with analogies and do other certain
analytical tasks and to measure what
kind of vocabulary they have that's a
pretty narrow range of what we could
consider to be intelligence and whether
it even measures any aspects of
intelligence is questionable depending
on whether you define intelligence as
someone's potential to perform or
someone's actual performance but humans
aren't just blank slates at birth we
don't all have the same amount of
potential to learn those skills and have
higher IQs some people are born with
biological predispositions to better
learn the skills that IQ measures but
after you're born your acquisition of
those skills is mostly determined by
your environment which accounts for most
of your IQ we don't know what the limits
of what a person's IQ can be unless they
have the right resources and the
phenomenon that the IQ scores of a
particular person tend to remain more or
less the same at different ages isn't
evidence that IQ is innate and
unchanging because of biology this just
shows what should be obvious that a
person's environmental conditions are
likely to stay the same throughout their
development and many studies have shown
that intervening in a child's
development with cognitive skills
training will raise their IQ and that is
because higher IQs are correlated with
better access to resources that foster
those cognitive skills and those
resources are more present in the lives
of children of higher socioeconomic
status there can be a huge difference
between what someone is capable of due
to their biological disposition and what
skills they obtain because of their
environment a French study published in
the journal Nature observed siblings
adopted by families of contrasting
economic status they track children who
had the same biological parents but were
adopted and raised from an early age by
different families and they took into
account those adoptive families
education occupations and income the
study found that being raised in a high
socioeconomic status home can boost IQ
12 to 16 points by the way that also
happens to be the approximate IQ
difference between the average white
person and the average black person
psychologist Eric Durkheim er conducted
a similar study but assessed
twins who were adopted into different
families so that the children's genetic
makeup would be 100% the same the study
found that the heritability of IQ among
children raised by families
low socioeconomic status was only around
10% and a little higher in more affluent
families this suggests that while yeah
IQ can be inherited from parent to child
to some degree children are less able to
benefit from their genetics if they're
raised in a lower socioeconomic
environment which is to say if you're a
rich kid you're going to have plenty of
educational opportunities and your IQ is
more likely to just be what it is
whether high or low but if you have
fewer educational opportunities your IQ
is much more likely to suffer from that
but like I said before even though some
of your IQ can be linked to genetics
there's no meaningful way to relate that
to race because there is an incredibly
huge amount of genetic variation inside
races but anyway if IQ tests are
evaluating people of drastically
different upbringing and environments
then their inherent intelligence is not
being assessed in a vacuum
instead IQ test scores are just arrived
from a number of variables that are hard
to measure everything from a person's
home life during their development to
the quality of their education to
whether or not they have attention
deficit issues to their actual
motivation to do well on the test itself
and skills measured on an IQ test are
not valued taught or used across all
groups of people to the same degree if
you take someone who came from a lower
socioeconomic class and had less access
to quality early childhood education
they are likely to score lower on an IQ
test let's take two people who were born
with the same level of innate
intelligence at Birth one of them is an
American with great access to quality
American education throughout their
development and the other lives in a
tribal community who had to learn an
entirely different set of skills to
survive and succeed in their society
which of these two people do you think
would score better on an IQ test IQ
tests largely measure a person's ability
to think abstractly and use theoretical
analysis but if a child isn't immersed
in that type of thinking during their
development they're not going to learn
as many of those skills American
children are more likely to develop
these skills than children in a third
world country and
of alleged white American children are
more likely to develop these skills than
a Hispanic American living in a
low-income neighborhood and it's a cycle
right well-educated people who make more
money have children who are given more
educational opportunities to develop
these cognitive skills and uneducated
people with less money are more likely
to raise children with that same lack of
opportunity another thing like I
mentioned before global IQs have been
rising since the beginning of the 20th
century this is also evidence that IQ
has more to do with environment than
genetics the scientific consensus is
that IQs around the world have been
rising at a much faster rate than could
even possibly be explained by genetics
human genes can't mutate that quickly so
this huge acceleration in IQ over the
past hundred years is most likely due to
globalization and dissemination of
Western education during that time the
skills assessed by IQ tests have become
more necessary and nurtured in more
parts of the world and in lower
socioeconomic echelon and so
understandably guess who has seen the
biggest leaps in IQ over the past
hundred years non-whites and
marginalized ethnicities within
different societies all of which
supports what we know about IQ being
more affected by environment than
genetics so to sum up race isn't even a
valid context to begin with when you're
talking about biology and IQ tests are
not the be-all end-all of measuring
intelligence but even when we are just
talking about IQ there is evidence that
genetics can determine IQ to some degree
but there is conclusive evidence that
environment plays a bigger role in
determining IQ assumptions we make about
groups of people have real-world
consequences the way we see people as
groups and as individuals should be
rooted in fact and even though racial
differences in IQ are grounded mostly on
environment having prejudices about
certain races is still racism one irony
is that people on the right
supposedly espoused the ideas of
individualism and personhood yet they
are usually the ones who want to make
these false judgments about groups of
people and make fallacious claims about
race and IQ another irony
is that people on the right are the
people who say pull yourself up by your
bootstraps but it's usually people on
the right who perpetuate these
inaccurate narratives about certain
races being genetically destined to be
less intelligent and less successful the
most important thing is that an
individual's race can't tell you
anything about their intelligence or
their character and human beings should
be judged on qualities other than their
IQ but there is certainly no current
scientific proof indicating that there
are differences in genetic innate
intelligence between the social lines
that we call race